welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Alan McHale an assistant professor of
history at Yale University he is a
historian of the early modern Muslim
world the Ottoman Empire and Egypt whose
research and teaching focused mostly on
the nature of early modern imperial rule
peasant histories environmental resource
management and science and medicine in
one of the first environmental histories
of the Ottoman Empire
professor McHale examines relations
between the Empire and its most
lucrative province of Egypt today we
talk with him about his award-winning
new book nature and empire in Ottoman
Egypt an environmental history
welcome professor McHale thanks very
much this is your first book and I think
it's such a novel idea what led you to
write it at the most basic level I was
interested in the history of the Ottoman
Empire in the Arab world the Ottoman
Empire ruled in most parts of the Arab
world for about 350 years so I was
curious about the obvious impact that
must have had on the region and then
also the region's impact on the Ottoman
Empire as a whole and on imperial rule
in in different parts of the Empire okay
and where does the Ottoman Empire fall
in terms of history what years and then
what was going on in Egypt during that
time okay so the conventional dates that
are given for the Empire are 1300 to
1922 okay so that's over 600 years and
the Ottoman Empire existed in what we
today called the Middle East in the
Balkans and in parts of North Africa
okay so it was a late medieval state an
early modern state a 19th century
modernizing state and then a participant
in World War one so it has a huge
a huge history in multiple places very
different sorts of regions with
different languages different cultural
traditions different religions so it
touched on many different parts of you
know what we now call the old world so
Europe and the Balkans obviously Africa
Iran and Central Asia Russia the
Mediterranean the Indian Ocean etc okay
and give us an overview of your book
okay a little bit about it okay so the
book as you mentioned in the
introduction is interested in at the
most general level of the relationship
between Egypt and the rest of the
Ottoman Empire to get at that
relationship I wrote an environmental
history because I came to see that that
was the best way of getting at this
relationship so Egypt was conquered by
Ottoman armies in 1517 okay
made one of the most important provinces
of the Empire over its history it proved
to be the most lucrative province in the
Ottoman Empire and then remained within
the ottoman fold historians disagree
about this but until the end of the 19th
century some said the beginning of the
19th century but I say the end of the of
the 19th century so my work is really
focused on the 17th and the 18th
centuries and I examine in each chapter
a different aspect of natural resource
management so this included water
obviously in Egypt the Nile is very
important so irrigation this also
included the production of food
resources so grains mostly and then also
I'm interested in the way that the
Empire managed the movement of wood to
the province of Egypt because Egypt was
an excessive producer of grain but
didn't have a lot of native timber
supplies which were needed for various
irrigation works other building projects
other sort of infrastructural
infrastructural projects so irrigation
tied Egypt in a very intimate way to the
rest of the Empire so we see a great
interest on
part of the central administration of
the capital in Istanbul modern-day
Turkey in the sort of nitty-gritty
day-to-day on-the-ground management of
even the smallest canals in very rural
parts of Egypt so we have a very strong
bureaucratic connection over the
management of water and the reason for
that was because Egypt was such such an
important producer of grain for feeding
different parts of the Empire so first I
examine the management of water and then
I show how food was moved to different
parts of the Empire how wood was brought
from from different parts of the Empire
to Egypt so the opposite direction
mostly from Anatolia southern Anatolia
so what is Turkey today and then also
from what what today is Lebanon and
parts of Syria and then I'm also
interested in in the labor that
undertook all of this and how that is
managed and then I end the book with an
examination of how this system changed
from the 18th century to the early 19th
century and how the management of
natural resources moved from being
controlled by local communities within
Egypt within an Imperial framework but
nevertheless on the ground by local
local communities to being managed more
centrally from Cairo and the
implications of that both for politics
for economic relations within the Empire
and then also for environmental
management okay and it's tell us about
your methodology it seems like it it
would be difficult to find all of these
types of information how did you go
about that
so before I began this project I was
also a little worried that these sorts
of issues would not would not be
adequately addressed by the archival
materials that we have on this period
because many historians obviously have
worked on this period none have really
dealt with environmental history or
environmental resource management now
looking back on it I see that you know
my fears were a little misplaced because
obviously irrigation had such a
Imperial such white imperial importance
and so there are many many records of it
so for my research I used archival
collections both in Istanbul so the
central repository of the Ottoman state
is in is in Istanbul and then I also use
the the records of local Islamic courts
throughout Egypt so I wanted to operate
both at an imperial level and then also
a local level and bring the two together
so that required using archival
collections in Ottoman Turkish and in
Arabic in Istanbul and then also in
Egypt when you looked at the records the
individual records what you know
basically what is it showing you mm-hmm
okay so for example in the core records
okay
you would have peasants from a certain
community coming and saying we are the
we're the farmers of village X and the
upstream village village Y has been
taking more water from the canal than is
their their historic allotted amount
therefore less water is coming to us so
we're not able to irrigate our fields in
the way that we need to to produce the
food that ultimately you the Ottoman
state will tax so you need to help us to
deal with this situation Wow very
interesting that they have you know such
detailed records like that can you give
us an example of how environmental
history helps us understand the Ottoman
Empire okay
usually Ottoman historians are
interested in a certain part of the
Ottoman Empire a province and in doing
that provinces history and yes in
relation to the Ottoman Empire but
really a history of that province where
they're interested in doing a history of
the capital in its institutions so I was
really attracted to doing an
environmental history of the Ottoman
Empire because it allows us to do I
think in a sort of integrative history
so for example I examine cases of the
building of dams in Egypt again to help
irrigate fields that would grow food
that would be shipped
to different parts of the Empire to
North Africa to parts of the Balkans to
parts of Anatolia etc mm-hmm
but because Egypt doesn't have native
wood supplies that would have to be
brought from elsewhere so I traced a
particular case in the 1720s of the
importation of wood from parts of
southwestern Anatolia so around what is
today Izmir and that would being brought
to Egypt then being shipped down the
Nile and then taken to a certain a
certain village to build a small dam so
in tracing this history it allows us to
connect the history of the harvesting of
wood and for instance the labor of the
Lumberjacks
in in south western Anatolia who
harvested the wood the the merchant
ships that brought that wood across the
Mediterranean to Egypt the sailors who
sailed it down the Nile ultimately to
the people who used it in the
countryside in Egypt to build this dam
that again it will irrigate water to
grow food that will be sent to different
parts of the Empire so environmental
history allows us to operate at these
different scales of the village right
the small scale nitty-gritty community
of the village all the way up to the
Mediterranean as a unit of analysis and
different parts of the Empire and it
allows us to bring in different actors
so in this case the Lumberjacks in
Anatolia and the farmers in in Egypt
very good and conclusions what are some
of the conclusions you reach in your
book so probably the main conclusion
that I reach is that the the local
management of these natural resource
processes was ultimately from from the
perspective of those involved more
equitable more sustainable and
ultimately better for their lives and
what do I mean by that in the 19th
century when much of the management of
irrigation was centralized by the
Imperial bureaucracy in Cairo this led
to the large-scale movement
of peasants brought to work on canal
projects rather than in the previous
centuries these canals being managed
locally it led to the salinization of
soil on these projects and ultimately it
led to less autonomy for these local
communities so I think there's a lesson
that can be exported to places outside
of the Ottoman Empire and outside of
Egypt in terms of the the local
oversight over not just natural
resources but over let's say local
resources more generally and what
happens when management of local
resources becomes more centralized or
more bureaucratized by some kind of
central administration yeah that makes
sense
final question I always like to know in
doing the research for the book was
there anything that particularly
surprised you I think the thing that
probably surprised me most was the level
of detail that I was able to find in
these different sources again we find
the enumeration of hundreds and hundreds
of people you know to the single
individual we find the weighing of for
instance rice down to the very minor
scale and there's just copious copious
amounts of sources about very small
scale nitty gritty kinds of things and
it's often said that the Ottoman Empire
sailed on a sea of paper and and that's
true we're just beginning to scratch the
surface of the sources that we have for
Ottoman history so I knew going in that
I would find a lot but the the level of
detail I think is what what really
surprised me so are you planning a step
number two after this book stand some of
the things that you found I am so in
reading these cases of irrigation repair
projects for the most part
I came to see that animal labor was used
in lots of these projects so used to
bring materials to the work site used to
Holloway dirt used sometimes even in the
dredging of canals and I found that
curious at first now again it's not it's
not very surprising when I say it and
then I started sort of cluing into
animals and I noticed that they were all
over the sources that I was reading so
for instance in the Egyptian countryside
the ownership of animals represented the
most significant form of capital for
rural Egyptians because technically the
ownership of technically they did not
own the land that they used but animals
represented some of their most important
forms of property so in my next book I
want to trace the importance of animals
to this rural economy so I think we
can't understand an early modern
agrarian society without understanding
the really important and multiple roles
that animals played in the society and
then I think there are important changes
that happen in in the latter part of the
18th century so I want to I want to work
on that and trace that in my next book
very good well we'll look forward to
that thank you so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work for more information about
professor Mikhail and his research
please visit our website at Yale edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale